[Music]
the interesting part about how the brain
works is that it loves novelty and so if
you present something over and over the
same thing to the brain it quickly
starts showing a smaller response this
is called repetition suppression in
other words the brain really cares the
first time there's a little less second
time by the third and fourth fifth that
the brain cares a lot less so what this
means is that we're always leaning into
the future we care about novelty but the
interesting part is we don't want too
much novelty because that's disorienting
so you might want to go to Burning Man
for five days but you don't want to live
there all year and so we're always
caught in this ground between
familiarity and novelty and this is
where creativity lives because brains
are looking for this balance and you can
see this in lots of ways just as an
example take skew Moore's
so skew morphs are these digital objects
that have a relationship to a physical
object so when you're saving something
on your computer you press the little
floppy disk which we haven't used for a
couple of decades now or you make a
phone call by pressing a handset which
is the old type of handset that kids
nowadays don't even know what that is or
you send an email by pressing an
envelope letter or send yo you throw
away your zeros and ones in a trash can
and so on so these are all illustrations
of the way that we like to have one hand
on the past when we make new leaps we
don't want them to be completely
unfamiliar just as an example with when
the iPad came out with digital books it
was on a wooden bookshelf and they were
books that sat on this wooden bookshelf
so the point is that we're always
keeping one hand on the past and then
you know one hand on the future and
that's where we are comfortable with
innovation when it comes to repetition
suppression you can measure this in the
brain you just show something to the
brain and you see a big response and
then you show it again and you see less
response then again you see less of
response and so on by about the 12th
presentation you're getting
very little response because the brain
just doesn't care so we're always
leaning into the future because we're
always looking for the next thing what's
interesting when when companies put out
their new and improved product it has to
have some relationship to the old one I
mean if if a cellphone company decided
to put out a triangular cell phone or
something weird like that it wouldn't
necessarily catch on we want things that
look pretty much like the old but they
have novelty to them now the interesting
thing is that when it comes to creation
it's impossible to know exactly how far
to travel from community standards so if
you stick too close you'll get passed by
if you go too far no one's going to
follow you there and there are so many
examples historically of this sort of
thing happening
so what creators actually what good
creators do is they cover the spectrum
this is this true of individuals as it
is for companies they cover the spectrum
where they're doing some things that are
sort of nearby and some things that are
whackier and whackier and this is how
they feel out the border of the possible
this is how they figure out what's going
to stick with their society because the
thing about any sort of creative act is
that you never know what's going to
stick what what will actually make a
difference in your society what's very
clear is that we are vessels of our own
space and time so the particular things
we create have to do with what we have
absorbed so if you compare you know 19th
century Japanese music to 19th century
French music to 19th century Kenyan
music and so on you'll see these are
extremely different but it's not that a
composer over here couldn't have done
what a composer over here was doing it's
simply that it wouldn't have stuck in
their culture it would have been strange
and wouldn't make sense why because what
we're doing is building on the
foundations of what has come before us
the interesting part is that all ideas
have a genealogy so what it seems so
often is that a great idea comes out of
the blue an example of that is the
iPhone when Steve Jobs announced that in
2006 one reporter called it the Jesus
phone it was it seemed so revolutionary
but in fact it has a very clear
genealogy that you can trace in 1993 IBM
introduced the Simon which was a
touchscreen cell phone now it was about
this big it was a giant thing that it
had a little touchscreen it was the same
idea over two decades earlier
and so each thing leads to the next in
progression which is not to say there
aren't you know big novel leaps forward
these happen all the time but what it is
it's absorbing things from our society
and bashing them together in new ways
and this is actually the basis of all
creativity
[Music]